hello everyone and welcome to a really
awesome game that happened yesterday in
the leeches titled arena
and i don't even have to look at the
game i just look at the number of
notifications i get on my phone with you
guys suggesting a game and i already
know it's a it's a
really wild one so as the title suggests
this is not an over exaggeration or
anything
uh but um you know best best for me to
just show it to you even though i know
probably most of you have seen it but
you know you never know
uh so without further ado let's check it
out uh like i said uh magnus carlsen
versus grandmaster watneg
and i don't know who this gentleman is
so i'm using the
image of mr hoody guy as we usually do
on this channel for those of you who
don't know
and of course when you're watching a
game uh featured by uh where mr hoodie
guys featured you have to be wearing a
hoodie yourself to
uh you know get um the the uh the full
experience
uh so and of course if you know who this
gentleman is do uh mention in the
comment section below i will pin
uh for everyone else to see so let's
dive straight into it magnus with the
white pieces opens with e4
we have d6 by mr hoodie guy knight the
c3 and the g6 now going for the pirates
defense we have d4 striking in the
center and
bishop to g7 now transposing in sort of
a modern defense and magnus immediately
strikes with h4
as one should always do when playing
bullet with knight to f6
and now bishop to e3 and here there are
some games where castles was played also
a6 is a known move uh but here uh we
have the immediate knight to c6 and it
is now
already as of move five that we have a
completely new game
so uh magnus continues with f3 he wants
to get a standard attacking setup with
queen d2 bishop e3 then g4 h5 you must
open the position and so on if black
decides to castle king side of course
so e5 now are wanting to open up the
center and
knight g to e2 black does castle king
side and now just queen to d2 preparing
the castle queen side
and start an attack on the king side so
d5
white king is still in the center of the
board so it does make sense to open up
the position
magnus castles queen side right into it
and now d
captures on e4 and here magnus starts
complicating with
d5 now it looks like a very scary move
uh although if you
don't uh don't uh trust magnus you could
just play
e captures nf3 and everything is
perfectly fine
uh however black trusted magnus and i
mean who wouldn't
and played knights to a5 but now uh this
only plays into white's position so
knight's the g3
we have e captures on f3 g captures on
f3 and now
c6 trying to undermine the center and of
course the white captures then black
gets uh
the queen's over the board and black is
very happy so magnus just continues
attacking with h5 now of course uh
if the knight or pawn captures you're
gonna open up the the king's defenses
uh c captures on the five now with a
massive center here planning d4 to win
more material and now bishop to g5 not
allowing d4 to come with a double attack
but black still plays it here
black should just play it safe play
something like knight back to c6 and
continue the game
but these d4 right away allows uh uh
white a bit too much because now the e4
square is available for the white knight
and this is something black even planned
for because after knight to e4
he played knight captures on e for
attacking the white queen now so he
wants to trade queens
magnus not interested he plays knight
captures on e4 and now we have f6
attacking the bishop here and now you
could move the bishop bishop h4 you
could even play bishop to e3
because captures is impossible queen
captures on d8 would happen
but magnus ignores the attack he just
continues his own attack
h captures on g6 uh sacrificing the
bishop we have
f captures and g5 and now it's hard to
find a good move here for white or
rather
other than rook captures on h7 there
really is no uh real way to continue the
attack
because for example if you capture with
the pawn ninjas king h8 and that king is
incredibly safe there you are never
getting to that king and this h7 pawn
really serves only as a shield to the
black king
but here after f captures mg5 magnus
plays the move from the thumbnail and
this is uh uh well i'm not gonna
go as far as to say this is uh like
niche medina versus chernikov but
in terms of you know how how how insane
a move
is uh it could very well be and here
magnus played queen captures on a5 he
sacrifices his queen in in a most uh
spectacular way offers a full queen and
there is no better move for black than
to capture the queen you have to capture
it
and ask white what are you even doing so
this is what black does we have queen
captures on a5
and now magnus plays bishop to c4 with
check
and okay if the king moves then rook
captures an h7 is checkmated that goes
without saying however
black played rook to f7 now blocking the
this attack
and now g captures on f7 with check king
to f8 and again
how do you continue the attack well
magnus plays knight to g5
now with ideas of knight captures on h7
with check as the f7 point is nicely
defended
uh but black takes this opportunity to
develop the dark square bishop and
get this rook active to help out with
the defense of the queening square
so bishop to f5 uh and now uh
okay now if you go for knight capture so
we're just going to have king to e7 and
there's again nothing to do here the f8
square is
very well defended so instead after
bishop to f5 we have rook d the g1
magnus shifts the rooks over to the king
side
uh we have rooked the c8 now with a lot
of pressure here
afterwards uh magnus's king if the
bishop moves it's going to be very scary
so bishop to b3
moving while defending the c2 pawn and
now
d3 and it seems like the end is near for
magnus
however knight captures on h7 with check
bishop captures an h7 and now rook
captures an h7 now with
a pressure on the bishop on g7 but black
doesn't care black just plays the rook
captures on c2
and now if the rook is accepted uh it's
you know that
it's a game over for white because queen
to c5 with
the threat of checkmate and the rook and
g1 is being threatened
and if you defend the rook then queen
the e3 check
if you move the king or or do something
weird queen t1 is coming so you have to
block with the rook
but now e4 and there really is no good
move here bishop captures b2 check is
coming you're going to pick up the rook
carson's entire position is falling
apart however after rook captures on c2
magnus doesn't grab the rook magnus
plays king to b1
he only needs one good move uh without
being in check and maybe he can
create something with the position so
here rook back to g2
not allowing rook captures and of course
if magnus captures this then he loses
immediately queen e1 check bishop d1 and
queen captures and d1 is checkmate
so you have to be very very careful
after this rook the g2 move
magnus played rook to c1 now planning to
cause some damage here with rook to c8
check
and of course black just goes back queen
to d8 the c8 square is now nicely
defended
we have rook c back to h1 now
with ideas of uh well doing some damage
along the h file
and now black needs a good move there
are many good moves here one such move
is
for example queen to d4 and that's just
it you don't really have a good way of
defending here
you're going to have to play something
but it's not going to be enough this is
just game over for white however
black thought that anything wins here
and of course this is a bullet game you
don't have a lot of time
played d2 makes sense uh you know the
the past pawn is
almost there but now uh feel free to
pause the video and
win this game for magnus while i give
you a couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations on
finding the only move that wins here and
for those of you who just want to enjoy
the show
it's rook to h8 with check and now there
is no good move here
uh king the e7 is a bit more resilient
but this was not played in the game in
the game
black uh black capture with the bishop
but i'm still gonna show what happens if
king to e7 we just capture on d8 and now
the queen exp
square is defended twice king captures
and now you play
rook the h8 with check again if bishop
captures you're just
going to bring the queen into the game
with check so black is not in time to
play a rook to g1
uh and if you don't do this if you play
king the e7 then we play
rook to e8 with check the the f7 pawn is
still
defended so that's uh out of the
question and after king 37 we're going
to play king to
c2 and now you can't queen the pawn
because the queen
king guards it and if you play rook to
g1 then king just captures here and this
is just game over there's no defense
against f8 queen
white wins material ended the game so
this was kind of uh
the most resilient way for black to
continue but in the game bishop captures
an h8 happened
but now magnus just goes for rook
captures an h8 with check
king to e7 and now rook captures on the
e8 now both the rook and the bishop
guard d1 square so you don't really
have anything here uh regarding checks
and even if you play king captures then
this is just uh queening with check
that's game over
so here rook the g1 check was played but
it
it doesn't help king to c2 now both the
king and the rogue guard the queen
queening square and that's it again if
you capture the rook just f8 queen with
check so rook the c1 check was played uh
trying to play at least something but
after king captures on d2
it was in this position on move 33 that
uh the grandmaster what neg
resigned the game as there is nothing
more to be done here
again if you capture the rook this is
just winning and well of course
the rook on c1 is hanging and if you
move the rook uh then you're just
getting checkmated whatever you play
just uh well f8 queen and that's
checkmate the bishop covers the e6
square
that's it so an incredible incredible
queen sacrifice
and uh well just shows you how how wild
these games can get and even though this
was a bullet game was played at a pretty
high level
and uh uh okay it will make no mistake
if this was a longer time format
such a such a queen sacrifice would like
work maybe one
one one in a thousand times but here it
worked and that's
uh why it's uh you know why it improved
our sunday
so and that's the game i hope you guys
enjoyed it uh
keep suggesting such games whenever you
see them because we are going to cover
them that's what we do here
i would like to thank mr hoodie guy
alejandra arowish patrick welfare
fred julio and diego montano for
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot i really appreciate it
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the magnus
crossing invitational checking up on
your wonderful suggestions and whatever
else happens in the chess world
so thank you all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day